all right well hi everyone nice to well
see many of you some of you just names
and black rectangles so hopefully
hopefully I'll get to know you all much
better over the next four weeks so will
this is an exciting time it's and this
is an exciting moment I hope in the
trajectory of of science and physics in
particular you know I've seen a bunch of
fields go through a bunch of cycles and
his heart typically works and you look
at the history of science this is
something that you see over and over
again at some moment there's some
methodological conceptual advance in
some field and lots of stuff gets opened
up and there's a period of some number
of years five ten when there's lots of
low-hanging fruit to be picked and lots
of exciting things happen lots of sort
of defining moments of the field occur
at that time and then after that there's
a long slog as one tries to go further
in that field and that might last 50
years a hundred years maybe more
and then eventually there's some
methodological advance that gets made
and then things.this sort of another
Cambrian explosion things open up again
exciting stuff happens so for physics
one could argue that in the world of
fundamental physics the the last kind of
great methodological advances were in
about the 1920s about a hundred years
ago
that's from the invention of general
relativity in 1915 which at the time was
not particularly notable and then to the
time of the creation of quantum
mechanics of quantum field theory in the
1920s that was a time of great
excitement at a time when physics really
advanced very rapidly then I suppose
it's fair to say there was another blip
50 years later in the 1970s I was lucky
enough to be involved in particle
physics back at the sort of the end of
that blip happening and
the neat thing is that when you're when
you're in this moment when sort of low
hanging fruit is being picked sort of
all of the all of the things that get
done end up being important for many
years afterwards so the exciting thing
is I think we're in that position again
for physics I mean I didn't really
expect to be here but things have worked
out vastly better than I had anticipated
and it's turned out that this whole sort
of stack of ideas around computation and
so on together with all the experience
and intuition that we've developed
around that has led us to a point where
I think we are at a moment of great
methodological advance for physics and
I'm hoping that this summer school will
be our opportunity to start exploring
and more broadly a bunch of those ideas
and to start picking kind of the
low-hanging fruit so to speak and so
I'll go over the next four weeks is to
to get some great projects done and sort
of get everybody here launched in this
kind of new direction in physics I would
say there's this there's this tradition
of calling the physics of a hundred
years ago modern physics I would like to
see this as a moment when we get to
define what modern physics means and I
study the history of science a bunch I
haven't actually studied that much the
history the early history of quantum
mechanics so I can't say exactly what's
involved and you know who's gonna play
the Heisenberg the Bohr the Dirac etc in
this moment but I think we have an
opportunity to do this kind of thing
again and I hope this is going to be a
launching point for that so what I
wanted to do this morning here was talk
a little bit about where we're at so far
in the way that I kind of see the kind
of the conceptual framework that we
built evolving some of the things which
we have figured out some of things that
we haven't figured out that we hope we
will be able to figure out and so on I
mean I would say that that the the basic
thing that I've been saying to lots of
people is you know in a sense finding
the fundamental theory of physics is
like sort of climbing the tallest
mountain and physics
and it's one of the things that's
important right now is that I think you
know we're we're finally on the right
mountain it's not clear how long it's
going to take to get to the summit but
we're finally I think on the right
mountain and by the way something that's
important for the world is it's kind of
a nice view even from where we are right
now and one of the things that's been
something exciting about this project is
the extent to which people in the world
who are generally interested in science
and it's progress we've been working
hard to sort of expose and open this
project to the point where such people
can can see what's going on and
potentially get involved and that's
that's something that I think is it's a
very unusual it's a lot of a unique
feature of this project made possible by
both the tools that were able to use and
the existence of things like
live-streaming and and so on and the
fact that I suppose this project I view
as being in a sense of project I never
really thought would come together in
the way that it has and so it's sort of
a in some ways a bonus project and that
makes it easier to think of sort of
confidently sharing it with the world
because it's it's something where
whatever happens is is is good so to
speak okay
well the the as I say we've I think
we've got a great framework now for for
making forward progress on sort of
finding fundamental theory physics it's
one of the things that we really want to
do is to leverage all the work that's
been done in physics in mathematics and
computation over the last 50 years
hundred years and so on and it's lots of
work to connect to those things because
a lots been figured out in those areas I
mean a lots been figured out often very
technically in in fundamental physics to
date and to really in a sense we have it
easy because if we were a hundred years
ago that would have been a zillion kinds
of phenomena that we would have to
connect our theories of physics to now
really essentially all
phenomena that are important for
fundamental physics have already been
sort of pre concentrated into general
relativity in quantum field theory and
the standard model of particle physics
and cosmology and so on so in a sense
our only job is to see whether we can
connect our models to those existing
models of physics it is my expectation
and it's what we're seeing already that
a lot of things where we said I wonder
why it works that way in in the existing
models of physics we get to say now we
know why it works that way and more than
that we get to see oh there are some
things that were never looked at in
standard models of physics where now we
know to look at them and now we start to
realize why there's something
interesting to see there and we start to
be able to predict things that nobody
had predicted before and so on so that's
the the story of sort of leveraging
modern physics leveraging the the
treatments of physics over the last
hundred years and and one of the big
surprises for me of this project is I
thought that as we built this kind of
computational direction in physics that
we would find that all of the ideas that
we encountered were new fresh ideas that
there were not things that connect in
any way to what has gone before actually
what we've discovered is something quite
different that we built this very
abstract framework and from the point of
view of this abstract framework we're
seeing connections to lots of what
seemed like abstract frameworks in
physics and also in mathematics that
have come before so one of the things
that I realized just just in the last
few weeks actually is one of the things
that's happened is we've sort of built
we're building this this kind of
theoretical framework that in a sense is
an ultimately minimalist ultimately
general ultimately abstract framework
and that but that framework it's it's a
it's a concrete framework it talks about
hypergraphs you can simulate it you can
get intuition from computer experiments
and so on but yet it's it's deeply
abstract minimal in general and the
thing that one of the things that I'm
realizing is that among its other roles
this kind of model is serving as a kind
of rosetta stone for a lot of these
kinds of abstract approaches that have
been
taken in the past and I view it
historically a little bit like the story
of the early days of universal
computation I mean there had been
Combinator's invented in the 1929 t20
there had been lambda calculus there
were general recursive functions these
were all things that were concepts on
their own that were abstract and
interesting and so on but then in 1936
Along Came Turing machines which were
more concrete more explicit and one
later discovered were completely
equivalent to all these other approaches
to computation I think we're seeing the
same kind of thing with a lot of
abstract approaches to to physics but
also to questions in mathematics and to
some extent to questions in in theory of
computation right now and so that's
something that I think is an unexpected
remarkable thing that's coming out from
our efforts to to find this underlying
model for physics is we built kind of a
very minimal very general model that can
serve as a sort of concrete gathering
point for lots of these abstract methods
that have been developed over
particularly over the last 30 or 40
years in in in physics and in
mathematics so I should say one of the
things that is really striking and the
physics we're doing is it needs a lot of
future mathematics let's say it leads it
needs a lot of mathematics well we can
see that mathematics has been going in
that direction
but it hasn't quite got there yet you
know I think um
Einstein was lucky in 1915 when he
developed general relativity because the
differential geometry and the theories
he needed for talking about curvature of
space they had just come into existence
maybe 20 years earlier so it was a case
where the mathematics that was needed
was was just available at that time I
think we're in a slightly different and
slightly a more difficult situation
because I think a bunch of the
mathematics we need it we need
mathematics as it is currently set up is
going in the right direction but it
isn't quite there yet and so we're going
to have to build a bunch of the
mathematics that we need alongside
building kind of the physical theory I
think that that's something that is not
unfamiliar in modern times in the
progress of mathematical physics but I
think what's
what's really interesting here is that
from these models that were studying
there are all kinds of questions about
or what does it mean to generalize let's
say just differential geometry to
fractional dimensional space how does
that really work well it will be really
good if we could just go to the
mathematics literature and just find an
answer to that question we can't but
what we've got now is a is a very
concrete set up where we can start to
study questions like that and I'm hoping
that in addition to informing lots of
things in physics what we're doing will
also inform developments in mathematics
and I'm really excited to see how that
works I think that in a sense as is
often the case in the progress of
physics what we do first is to hack
through the mathematics I mean it's
something like path integrals in quantum
mechanics we're still kind of even 50
years later physics is more than 50
years what is it 70 years now the
physics is still kind of sort of hacking
its way through the mathematics of that
it works but if you really ask for the
mathematical I dotting and T crossing
isn't quite there yet same thing is true
actually for something that we make
direct use of which is things like the
derivation of the fluid equations from
molecular dynamics that's something that
you know Boltzmann started talking about
in the 1860s 1870s and still the
mathematics of that is not fully nailed
down but we're using those those kinds
of ideas in our derivations of of
continuum physics from discrete
underlying structures and so on and it
turns out it looks like it doesn't
really matter what the what the full
nailing down of that mathematics is but
I wouldn't count on that and I think
maybe what we're doing gives finally an
impetus to nail down the mathematics
which amounts to the mathematics around
the reasons for the validity of the
second law of thermodynamics among other
things so the other thing we get to
leverage is modern computing the I think
in a sense this project has been made
possible by both conceptual and
practical aspects of computation
conceptual in the sense that
in the fact that I've been working for
the last 40 years
on trying to find the right way to
represent computational ideas in an
explicit language that us humans can
understand and that's kind of what's led
me to the kind of full-scale
computational language that we've been
building all these years in molten
language but that effort to kind of
define a computational language which
makes a bridge between sort of the
computational universe and what we
humans understand that's kind of a
critical piece of what one needs I think
to understand how to make a fundamental
theory of physics and that's certainly
what we're what we're leveraging in
attempting to to make the the models
that we're making right now
so the first first thing is kind of just
this the gradual greater understanding
of how one can think about computational
ideas how how we can humanize in a sense
computational ideas to the point where
we can understand what's what's possible
in the computational universe we can
find the right kind of slice of the
computational universe to to start
looking at and to explore so that that's
been one important piece to this picture
is sort of the progressive levels of
abstraction that we've understood
instead of representing the
computational universe in a way that we
humans can understand now I have to say
one sort of embarrassing feature for me
is in a sense
the models that were using right now for
fundamental physics are models that in
some sense I should have been able to
figure out forty years ago because in in
Mathematica and Wolfram language in the
predecessor of these things as system
called SMP that I built around 1979 all
of these were based on one key idea that
I kind of got as an abstraction of ideas
from mathematical logic from from the
early 1900's which was the idea that of
representing the computational process
as transformations on symbolic
expressions but in all those years in
working on computational language what I
thought about doing was having those
symbolic expressions represent real
things that
we care about you know addition doing
integrals computing combinatorial things
you know deploying programs to cloud
servers all those kinds of things that
that these symbolic expressions that our
language fundamentally manipulates were
things that had a meaning that we
already knew the the this sort of what I
realize in a sense in retrospect is that
the models were using for physics are
use the infrastructure of this idea of
symbolic expressions and transformations
with symbolic expressions but none of
their actual built-in meaning it is a
use of the kind of the the the
infrastructure of symbolic expressions
and and their transformation but not the
layer of meaning that we had always that
I had always put on top of these things
for the purpose of connecting them to
things that we want to do
computationally so in a sense these
models that we've developed are are are
kind of the the ultimate dessicated
version of what I've been doing for 40
years of transformations for symbolic
expressions except now the symbolic
expressions are in bulk there might be
10 to the 400 of them in our universe
that represent our our universe and
they're not only are they in bulk in and
of themselves they mean nothing
they are just representing let's say the
atoms of space and there's nothing
there's no particular you don't get to
call one atom of space you know plus
another atom of space integrate or
something they they don't mean anything
on their own they only in the aggregate
means something important and there's
something important they mean is
potentially the physics of our whole
universe so so that's some that's kind
of one way in which computation enters
what we're trying to do another way that
it enters what we're trying to do is
just the practicality of being able to
do computer experiments I mean this
whole idea of seeing whether there was
sort of a whether there's sort of a a
computational way of representing
physics for me that was something that
emerged as an idea as a result of doing
computer experiments I mean back when I
did physics for a living
the
brief was take quantum field theory and
general relativity and figure out given
those theories as as given so to speak
figure out what you can figure out about
how the universe must work from those
theories but what I realized in the
years after that in the in the early
1980s from doing these experiments on
actual computational systems on very
simple programs like cellular automata
what I realized was that even though to
my great surprise even though the the
program might be really simple the
behavior might be very complicated and
that kind of inspired the notion that
planted the seed of the idea that
perhaps there might be underneath all of
the sort of richness and complexity that
we see in physics there might be
something which amounts to a simple
computational rule and that's kind of
what slowly got me started on the
direction that's led to the models that
we have today now you know in in the
it's always a challenge in these things
to understand not only the sort of the
mechanics of what one has to do but also
its context and I think many of the
discoveries that I've made a discovery
that could have been made I think many
years earlier what was missing was not
the mechanical capability to let's say
do the computer simulation or whatever
else what was missing was the kind of
conceptual framework to understand why
one should care about those kinds of
things
to understand why one should care that
systems were generating intrinsic
randomness why one shouldn't just view
that as being oh that's a that's a
nuisance what we really care about is
the regularity of these systems to
understand that there's something
important in sort of the generation of
things like complexity and systems
rather than that that's just sort of a
nuisance and not the thing that we
should be concentrating on if we're
doing science so so it is I think very
much with this with what we're doing in
physics that sort of a we're having an
increasing understanding about so what's
important to focus on in thinking about
physics I would say the the big surprise
so so that the story that I the way I
thought things would play out is maybe
there's a simple rule that underlies all
of physics but it will be
computationally irreducibly hard
to figure that out in the sense that one
of the things that I discovered as a
result of exploring some of the
computational universe of simple
programs is this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility that when
you look at the actual behavior of a
computational system even though you may
know its rules and its rules may be
completely deterministic it may require
an irreducible amount of computation to
work out what the system actually does
you know you can trace the actual
million steps that the system takes but
you can't expect to kind of jump ahead
and figure out what the system will do a
million steps in the future just by
using an easy piece of math let's say I
mean in a sense the the people in the
last 300 years who've worked on kind of
the mathematical approach to science
that kind of got born 300 years ago now
with the efforts of Galileo and Newton
and people like that that approach to
science the the the thing that's always
really cool there is that we can say yes
we describe the universe in these
mathematical terms and just by being
clever in the mathematics we can figure
out lots of stuff about how the universe
works without having to explicitly
simulate anything in the universe by
just we can you know figure out sort of
what the the idealized planet will be
we'll do a million revolutions around
its star from now without having to
trace those million revolutions just by
using some mathematical formula and
plugging in the numbers and and jumping
ahead well so computational
irreducibility says in general you can't
do that and one of the discoveries of
exploring the computational universe is
the computational irreducibility isn't
just an obscure footnote type issue it's
an issue that's right in your face all
the time all over the place I would say
that for people who aren't familiar with
this kind of logical structure the the
the idea of computational irreducibility
is really a consequence of this more
general thing that I call the principle
of computational equivalence and that
has to do with the question of when you
look at different computational systems
how can what when you compare their
computational capabilities how do they
compare and the surprising thing that I
figured out in the
80s and early 1990s was that if you look
across all these different kinds of
systems that you can imagine
constructing or finding that are the you
can think of them any system that
operates according to rules you can
think of as a computational system and
all of these systems that we can imagine
constructing explicitly we can ask what
level of computation are they capable or
do they typically do and the big
surprise was that even when the rules
are very very simple the level of
computational sophistication seems to be
exactly the same and so that has had
predictions like the prediction that
even among the very sort of simplest
cellular automata or Turing machines the
even the simplest ones that show
non-trivial behavior should be universal
computers and we know in both of those
cases we know for sure that that's true
now so that's evidence for this
principle of computational problems but
anyway the principle of computational
equivalence is kind of sets up this we
can think of our efforts to make
predictions a sort of a competition
between the system we're trying to
predict and us as humans mathematicians
computers whatever trying to sort of
outrun the actual behavior of the system
itself and the principle of
computational equivalence says because
we are computationally equivalent to
those systems
we can't ever expect to sort of outrun
their behavior and so to us those
systems will always seem to be
computationally irreducible so I thought
that was what was going to happen in our
efforts to analyze physics that we'd
have is an in fact I had started looking
at simple potential rules for physics
back in 1990s and the the the typical
sort of experience and my paradigmatic
assumption was the principle of
computational equivalence is going to
rule all so to speak and and it's going
to limit us from from what we're able to
to start to see and so what that would
mean is that yes we might be able to
follow you know a billion steps of the
evolution of some particular very simple
underlying rule but those billion steps
might correspond to I don't know ten to
the minus hundred seconds in the
evolution of the universe and we
wouldn't be a
to tell whether our particular rule that
we could run for that that large number
of steps to ask the very small amount of
time in the physical universe would
correspond to the actual physics that we
see and we know about from the last
hundred years of physics about the
universe as a whole so that was what I
kind of thought was going to happen the
big surprise that I saw hint saw but
didn't take them as seriously as I
should have done back in the 1990's is
that there's actually a layer of
computational reusability on top of this
potential computational irreducibility
of these the sort of operation of these
underlying rules and that layer of
computational reusability is very rich
in fact it seems that layer of
computational reusability may include a
lot of what we know in physics and
that's the that for me has been one of
the biggest sort of conceptual meta
surprises of of what we've been doing
the last six months or so and it's it's
really what's allowed it to make the
kind of I think quite spectacular
progress that we've been able to make I
don't know how long it's gonna go I
don't know how how deep this kind of
layer of computational reducibility is
going to be before we hit this kind of
bedrock of computational irreducibility
I mean I might say that one of the
reasons that that intuition was
difficult for me is that in studying
cellular automata back in the 1980s one
hits this wall of computational
irreducibility very quickly so I was
fortunate enough to know and and get
interested in the project a bunch of top
mathematicians in back in the back in
the 1980s and they were very frustrated
with cellular automata because they had
all these sophisticated mathematical
tools and they started sort of picking
away at cellular automata and the
pickaxe is broke so to speak despite
considerable effort they really weren't
able to say much at all about things
like cellular automata they kind of hit
this wall of computational
irreducibility almost immediately and I
thought the same thing was going to
happen in studying fundamental physics
it hasn't now after the fact as is so
often the case I could say it's kind of
obvious it wouldn't happen that way why
is it obvious well if the whole world
was computational irreducible we humans
would have a very
hard time predicting what was going to
happen saying anything making any kinds
of plans about about our what we do or
anything because what we would be
running into is all the components of
the universe operating this
computationally irreducible way and none
of the physics none of the science that
has been possible to do in the last few
hundred years none of that would have
been possible because a lot of that is
living in the world of computational
reducibility
so in a sense it should have been
obvious um but it wasn't at least to me
but what we found the the sort of
exciting thing that we found is that yes
there is this layer of computational
reusability that sits on top of these
underlying models that we have and that
and here's the amazing thing that that
layer of computational reducibility
maps into essentially the big
discoveries of physics from the last 100
years
things like relativity quantum mechanics
and so on these are in a sense generic
features of these models that don't
require digging into the kind of
computational irreducible bedrock they
there are things that can be seen just
by operating at this sort of
computational reducibility layer above
that and that's the as I said I don't
know how far it's gonna go and hopefully
in these in these few weeks we'll learn
a little bit more about just how far it
can and cannot go I should say that
there is again looking back at sort of
obvious so to speak and and I really
knew some of this there is a great
example from the past of sort of this
layer of reducibility sitting on top of
irreducibility and that's the whole
story of the second law of
thermodynamics and the emergence of
continuum behavior from discrete
molecular dynamics
I mean it's people knew in the 1800's
they knew partial differential equations
that govern things like fluid flow then
area Stokes equations and so on but as
it became clear that that fluids were
actually made of discrete molecules the
question arose so how do these continuum
fluid equations arise from discrete
molecular dynamics and there was some
confusion about this and there remains
some confusion about this but
fundamentally the answer is that
although the details of that
of those underlying merkulov dynamics
may have what in modern terms we would
call lots of computational
irreducibility the the kind of the
emergent continuum behavior of the
system shows computational reduce
ability now of course with something
like the navier-stokes equations for
fluid flow and fluid turbulence and so
on
those equations have only a certain
amount of computational reduce ability
there they're plenty hard to actually
solve and that's a sign of some
computational irreducibility that starts
to poke its head up in in looking at the
navier-stokes equations and presumably
we will soon find the same kind of thing
as we look at physics we'll see things
we're nominally well general tivity is a
good example where nominally well the
equations are comparatively simple but
when you start actually solving them all
kinds of elaborate things happen which
represent I think in some cases the you
know computational irreducibility sort
of poking its head out so there's a
question in as we look at fundamental
physics of you know how deep is this
layer of computational reducibility how
much can we figure out that you know I
will be amazed if things like the
electron muon mass ratio are generic and
live in this layer of computational
reducibility it is my expectation that
things that specific will be things that
require sort of digging into the
computational irreducible layer probably
the three for the number of dimensions
of space will require that too although
I'm not sure about that I have sort of a
faint hope that local gauge invariants
and the local gauge groups you know sc3
cross su 2 cross e 1 of the standard
model of particle physics and so on that
those things might live in the
computational irreducible layer it might
be possible to say that for example you
know that things must always be a
subgroup of e8 or something like this
and in terms of local gauge invariance
that there might be statements of that
kind or there might be statements about
perhaps I don't know whether
supersymmetry is going to turn out to be
real but there might be statements about
that that can be made generically that
don't require that where we have to say
it's irreducible there's computational
irreducibility and the specifics of how
the you know the gauge
who gets spontaneously broken and the
exact details of the higgs potential
this kind of thing but there might be
something generic that can be said I
don't know yet
um and there's that there's this I think
this is that one of the exciting things
to explore is what is generic what can
we talk about without digging into that
irreducible layer and what can we not
and then the other thing is to work up
the other way from this kind of
irreducibility from actually looking at
individual specific underlying rules and
seeing what their behavior is because
one of the features of computational
irreducibility is that it's sort of a
necessary consequence of the existence
of computational irreducibility
that there are an infinite collection of
pockets a real reduced ability that
exists in an overall computationally
irreducible system and so one question
is where are those pockets of
reducibility
for the model that is physics and
perhaps the reducibility that we have
found in existing physics is only one
layer of reducibility that can be found
then there are other ones those other
ones might as I'll maybe talk about a
bit later represent an essentially
different reference frames and rule
space different completely incoherent
ways in which we can view the universe
but we're nevertheless we can find
reducibility and in a sense
predictability in the universe and I
think that the that that's some but we
may also find pockets of reducibility
that exists and are accessible from our
traditional ways of thinking about
physics that we our civilization has had
so to speak and those other pockets
might give us very interesting things
where we can say yes point the telescope
in that direction go observe this thing
this is what you will see I don't know
yet
that's that's sort of an exciting
possibility I mean I would say that talk
about this more later but this whole
question about and let's just talk a
little bit about kind of the arc of new
theories new approaches in science and
and how that tends to work I mean one of
the things if you look back at the
history of physics the history of other
kinds of areas um one of the things that
you see is when a new conceptual
framework comes into existence the major
first step is can you explain what was
already known
that's the first thing to do if you
can't explain what was already knowing
the thing you've got is not a step up so
to speak and so we are very much I think
now at the stage of can we explain
what's already known can we make in a
sense the theoretical predictions yes
there will be fermions and bosons yes
there will be these particular features
of cosmology or whatever else can we
make those theoretical predictions it's
going really really well doing those
things but that's kind of in a sense the
the stage we're at you know if you look
sometimes the it's sort of interesting
to look at the history of these things
you know you can go back to Copernicus
for example 500 years ago and you can
say you know Copernicus had a better
theory for how the solar system works
but the Ptolemaic system did just fine
at predicting the positions of planets
and in fact as a matter of sort of the
technology what was done you know we're
still effectively using epicycles today
inside the the practical ephemera teas
that we use in like Wolfram language or
something to predict the motion of
planets but the conceptual framework
that Copernicus provided was a much
better conceptual framework that allowed
many more things to be built on top of
it but in a sense the the early steps
there were can you explain what was
already known before you start going and
building new things on a particular
conceptual framework and and that sort
of the stage right now it's worth so in
an interesting analogy with the
situation with with if we look at this
sort of the Ark of people trying to
understand fundamental physics it's
actually you would think that trying to
understand the fundamental physics the
the fundamental structure of a universe
would have been a big time activity
throughout the history of science it
really hasn't been it's really a
minority interest thing it's something
where people say oh and yes if that will
be very interesting if we could do it
but it seems really hard and and you
know that the trajectory has started
with sort of you know any
self-respecting philosopher in ancient
Greece having some theory of the world
interestingly they had a lot of good
ideas I mean one of the fundamental
ideas they had is maybe the world is
made of a large number of identical
objects that's not to me self-evidently
obvious given that you
at the world on a large scale but that's
an idea that they had and they had a
bunch of sort of related ideas about you
know they had ideas about souls and so
on which is kind of a a an allegorical
way of talking about the idea of
computation um but without you know
before we had sort of computers as a as
a medium for thinking about what a sort
of an abstract soul like thing might be
we couldn't do much else but to talk
about it in this kind of abstract way so
you know if we if we look at kind of the
history of attempts to find fundamental
theories of physics that was kind of one
step then the next really big step was
1600s and the effort to realize that you
could use mathematics as a way to to
think about how the universe might be
put together I might say I think it's
worth remembering an often unsung piece
of heroism in the in the history of
science was the invention in the 1400s
through the 1600s of mathematical
notation before that time mathematics
was hard to do in a streamlined way
because one was using just sort of words
in languages to represent mathematics
one didn't have sort of a a good
language to represent a good notation
symbolism and so on to represent
mathematics people hadn't invented plus
signs and exponents and all those kinds
of things before that time it was that
that enabled the creation of algebra
later enabled the creation of calculus
and basically gave one the sort of
mathematical way of thinking about
science that provided this kind of the
revolution in thinking about physics
among other things in the 1600s I'd like
to think that in modern times we've been
engaged in a similar activity of finding
not a notation for mathematics but in
notation for computation and in a sense
the 40 years or so that I've spent kind
of building computational language
that's all about kind of building in a
sense of notation for thinking about
things computationally and it's a
necessary feature I believe insofar as
we were making good progress in physics
now what needed to happen was the
creation of that kind of computational
note
for thinking about things
computationally just like before the
developments of the 1600s what needed to
happen was the development of
mathematical notation that made it
possible to sort of talk in a
streamlined way about mathematical ideas
but in any case that was the sort of the
big surprise of the 1600s was you could
use these abstract mathematical ideas to
make statements about the physical world
and to to say things that were fairly
globally applicable you know the
universal law of gravitation and so on
actually worked well then at the time
people were sort of wondering oh well
could you know could the whole world be
made of corpuscles that are sort of
connected together by gravity something
like that it wasn't was kind of like
well there's probably some way of
thinking about this but it's all a
little bit distant from you know let's
go figure out how comets work first well
then you know in the 1800's as atoms
became more of a more of a real thing
that I mean it had been a debate from
since antiquity you know was the world
fundamentally discrete or fundamentally
continuous was light fundamentally
discrete or fundamentally continuous it
started to become clear that atoms
really existed as things in chemistry
things to be seen in Brownian motion and
you know by the end of the 1800s atoms
were definitely a thing and one knew
that matter was actually made of
discrete stuff so then but nevertheless
there was this kind of overlay of
thinking about things in terms of
partial differential equations thinking
about things in terms of continuous
mathematics leveraging the the sort of
powerful ideas of calculus to be able to
do physics and that was working really
well but the then there were things
people couldn't explain and that's what
led to quantum mechanics and led to this
kind of belief in the 1920s that yes
there was a sort of continuity in the
fundamental equations of physics but
somehow just like they had turned out to
be atoms of matter there would turn out
to be other kinds of discreteness in the
world and that was quantum mechanics and
so one of the things that and so that
was
a new conceptual framework which which
among other things took physics even
further into the realm of abstract
mathematics of even further into the
don't worry about how it really works
just calculate things kind of mode of
thinking about physics because quantum
mechanics was hard to wrap one's head
around from a conceptual point of view I
think one of the exciting things about
tum our models is I think we finally
understand sort of why quantum mechanics
works the way it does I have to say I
consider myself still still in the early
stages of really wrapping my brain
around what we now can understand about
quantum mechanics I mean I'm it's clear
we can go further than the quantum
mechanics that I've known for the last
comes to 50 years that is sort of the
traditional approach to quantum
mechanics but I suspect that there will
be a sort of a jumps of intuition that
it's possible to make by looking at
quantum mechanics in the way that we can
now do in our models and that have not
been accessible with sort of the
traditional mathematically based way of
thinking about quantum mechanics but any
case I one of the things that's been
sort of remarkable is in the early days
of quantum mechanics people thought okay
we're going to get it we're going to
figure out everything we're going to
figure out how space works and time and
everything and in fact in the very early
days of quantum mechanics people thought
space was going to be quantized just
like all the other things they were
finding with quantized they didn't
manage to make that work didn't manage
make it consistent with special
relativity in particular and so that
idea was kind of abandoned and sort of
the issues that have led to it that were
the infinities in quantum field theory
were kind of resolved using
renormalization in the 1940s and this
whole sort of idea of space might be
discrete just disappear well meanwhile
there was sort of the separate branch of
thinking about computation and Turing
machines and things like that and I have
to say right up until the 1980s possibly
even beyond people when when I would
talk about computation as a paradigm for
talking about physics
physicists would mostly say oh no no but
that's not really about physics because
we know that physics is a continuous
thing governed by differential equations
that computation thing is just a
representation of the things as humans
build as computers
it's not something to do with the way
the physical world works fact Alan
Turing himself seem to believe that
towards the end of his life in the in
the early 1950s he started working on
things in physics and biology and he was
like now we're gonna use partial
differential equations he didn't imagine
that that Turing machines might actually
be the underlying stuff relevant for
physics as well as for thinking about
computation so that sort of notion but
that might be relevant didn't really
emerge
I think perhaps some work of mine was
was part of what pushed that idea that
computation was a relevant way to think
about physics
even though physics had traditionally
been worked on in terms of in terms of
differential equations when I think in
much more recent times the whole quantum
information movement has has further
emphasized sort of the the bringing
together ideas from computation and
ideas from physics but you know one of
the things that that has happened I mean
in a sense in our efforts to define a
fundamental theory for physics it's kind
of strange how barren the landscape has
been in terms of other efforts to do
this back in the in the 1930s there were
ideas about how this might work a kind
of unified field theory that was that
was sort of a thing that was much talked
about the collusive klein theory there
all kinds of other things that were sort
of leveraging something like general
relativity with some kind of nod to
quantum mechanics to bring us some sort
of unified theory of the world
well then later on when it became clear
in the in the 1970s the quantum field
theory it had not been clear in the in
the 1960s it was a big model whether
quantum field theory was actually a good
description of microscopic phenomena or
not whether maybe generic s-matrix
theory of just looking at sort of
consistency conditions are on on quantum
amplitudes was the right thing to do
rather than trying to actually compute
things using Fineman diagrams and so on
from quantum field theory but it became
clear by by by the time when asymptotic
freedom was discovered in 1973 in QCD
that yes quantum field theory really
could be used to actually compute things
it wasn't just a question of finding
these consistency conditions and things
one could actually compute things at
least up to a point in front a field
theory that got really hard really fast
to do that but um then are the sort of
an idea well they're these engage groups
you know we've discovered there's this
you know this unification of weak
interactions with electromagnetism and
so on sort of showed up the the
understanding that spontaneously broken
gauge theories were in Eliza ball which
gave them kind of a seal of approval for
quantum field theory happened and and by
the end of the 1970s there was kind of a
as my former friend I would say Murray
gell-mann always used to say there's an
air of grand unification the that
there's this idea that maybe all of the
features of physics would be able to be
unified in some sort of grand gauge
theory that idea kind of evaporated when
proton decay was not observed because
that was sort of one of the consequences
of at least the simplest of those kinds
of models and then so so that sort of
big approach around 1980
we're almost there we've almost got a
fundamental theory of physics it's going
to be some you know s oh 10 gauge Theory
etc etc and it's going to explain
everything in the world that that kind
of didn't quite make it and then the the
annoying feature was the fact that
gravity general relativity just didn't
fit into this framework when you've
tried to analyze gravity using the ideas
of quantum field theory you ended up
with a very poorly behaved quantum field
theory that couldn't really be corralled
into this framework of renormalization
and so on
that was being used for existing quantum
field theory and so then starting in the
1980s that kind of the big push in
fundamental physics was various theories
of quantum gravity and how you could get
sort of an understanding of gravity in
this quantum framework and and things
like you know hooking radiation and
black holes and so on have been
discovered as a theoretical construct
and it was sort of became clear that
that was you know black holes were a bit
more like particles than why to imagine
and one could talk about their quantum
mechanics and so on and that was sort of
a large developments and that led to a
bunch of sort of mathematical
constructions were led to the rebirth of
string theory which had previously been
invented
for another purpose in in in theory of
strong interactions it led to all sorts
of I don't know things things the spin
networks ideas things in you know loop
quantum gravity related ideas all kinds
of all kinds of abstract ideas about how
the universe might be set up um things
in conformal field theory and so on
things that have built pretty tall
towers of kind of mathematical physics
but there was a little bit of a hope in
the 1990s that string theory would
somehow converge on a sort of
fundamental theory of everything M
theory was the big hope there didn't
work out um string theory is a good
example actually at that time of a of a
fundamental theory that you should
originally you should be suspicious
about because in a sense of criterion
for theories is this you know how much
do you get out versus how much you put
in and do you if you put your your your
simple things in and then maybe it's
hard work but you can compute what
happens that comes out and you can
compare that with what you know to be
true you know how does that how does
that fare um I would say one of the
great things about the models were
working with now is that's going just
great for string theory it ran into
trouble it was like well the world has
to be ten dimensional but we can get
around that by doing this and by by
building this fairly elaborate structure
now I suppose sometimes in the history
of physics these fairly elaborate
seemingly kludgy structures I'm thinking
for example the Higgs mechanism these
seemingly kludgy structures end up being
real they end up being real things but
an awful lot of the time they end up
just being nonsense actually um and I
think that the in string theory a lot of
great mathematics mathematical physics
has been developed around string theory
that doesn't really depend on the
details of the how we're actually going
to get to sort of a fundamental theory
of physics but those sort of suspicious
things that happen and really just
didn't pan out that that string theory
would lead directly instead of a
straight line to a fundamental theory of
physics and so by now and in our efforts
to to make
this fundamental theory of physics it's
a barren landscape you know if you ask
what are the existing big pushes in
physics things like understanding the a
DSC ft correspondence in so the merger
between general relativity and quantum
field theory that's something that was
originally discovered in the 1990s still
being explored very actively today it's
a great an interesting thing which I
think has a lot of dovetails in a very
beautiful way with with our models I
think it's all the story of the
relationship and to talk about the
specifics of our models it's all to do
with properties of the multi way causal
graph and it all has to do with sort of
the branchial side of that and the
physical space-time side of that and the
correspondence between those two things
represented in the multi way causal
graph that I think is the story of the a
DSC of T correspondence although we
don't know the details the agent may be
somebody here will figure out more of
that and it will be a terrific thing but
to me in any case I don't think people
who work on ADF C of T for example would
say you know we're very close to having
a fundamental theory of physics and it's
based on this it's more we're building
infrastructure that will one day be
relevant to a fundamental theory of
physics and by golly they're right I
think that is that infrastructure is
highly relevant to the things that we're
doing which do have the serious promise
of providing an underlying theory of
physics so in any case I was some I was
talking about kind of the the role of
different kinds of kinds of methodology
and kinds of thinking in what we're
trying to do and I was talking about
computation and about the importance of
of using computation not only as a as a
source of conceptual structure but also
as something to build intuition and for
me the important thing that started for
me in the early 1980s was just run
computer experiments you know I did that
lots on cellular automata I've started
to do that and lots of other kinds of
systems the kinds of things that are the
models that were using now are those
models are very abstract it makes it
more difficult to visualize to get into
our brains sort of what's going on in
these models and so it's required more
of development of graph as realization
and things like that to get to the point
where we actually
routinely get some idea from looking at
things what's going on in these systems
but I think one of the things that's
important and one of the important types
of studies that needs to be done is
these kinds of computer experiment
empirical studies that turn that to to
sort of build intuition discover
phenomena that can then be analyzed so
you know for me it's been critical to
sort of build this intuition about how
how this these kinds of underlying rules
what their consequences are because that
intuition informs how we can start to
build sort of higher-level discussions
of what's happening now it's turned out
as I mentioned that there's this kind of
layer of computational reducibility
and some of the investigation of that
can be done without specific reference
to particular you know computer
experiments and so on I mean you don't
need you can figure out things about the
derivation of the navier-stokes
equations for example without knowing
the specifics of let's say I did a
derivation based on underlying cellular
automata back in the mid-1980s without
knowing the details of those underlying
cellular automata but it's really really
useful to do those experiments because
actually there's all kinds of things
that you don't expect I mean one of my
mantras about doing computer experiments
is the computational animals are always
smarter than you are
and what I mean by that is you might
have some theory that oh that can't
possibly be a way that a system like
this can behave in such and such a way
and then you actually you know enumerate
a million cases and six of them behave
in some way that is completely
unexpected and completely violates the
thing you thought was the theorem I mean
proving theorems are nailing all the
things down is really hard and sometimes
and it's it's really hard for us humans
when we do it by computer it's really
hard for us humans to understand what
the computer did but to me you have some
conceptual idea you you you you have to
get this context for what it is even
worth looking at and computer
experiments then you do the experiments
you do them carefully you find out that
yes there are these things which work
the way
you expected but often you find by golly
there are these things over here that
work in a completely unexpected way
where something sort of slipped through
the cracks of how you were thinking
about things and you discover something
different and some of that slipping
through the cracks has been absolutely
critical for understanding how physics
could emerge from these underlying
simple models and so in terms of things
that we'll do at the summer school I
think one important direction is sort of
this methodology of doing computer
experiments being able to learn how to
do a good clean computer experiment you
know have as little extra fluff in the
experiment as possible and have it be as
as direct as possible understand how to
sort of deduce useful things from these
experiments and then understand how to
connect them to sort of larger
conceptual points well the you know I do
want to say
um the all right so so um I was was
talking about kind of well okay so I I'm
talking some more about some kind of the
the conceptual framework the role of
computation we talked a little bit about
computer experiments I would say the
other big thing that we're just starting
to understand is theoretical thinking in
computation and computer science and the
use of that to understand physics one of
the sort of big meta discoveries of very
recent times is the the correspondence
between ideas about distributed
computing and ideas about physics and
the realization that distributed
computing in a sense is the same as
physics and that the questions of you
know race conditions in in distributed
computing being essentially the same as
branch pairs and quantum mechanics all
these kinds of things that that well we
can make this direct sort of dictionary
correspondence between what what we're
doing in physics and what we think about
in distributed computing I might say in
terms of sort of the making of
dictionaries that's one of the things
that I think is a is an important thing
that I hope will have a trance for for
people to work on a bit in the next four
weeks is making these dictionaries of
the correspondence between things we're
studying and things that are out there
in the world so for example making the
dictionary that goes from what we're
thinking about in these models of
physics and various areas of mathematics
whether it's tapas theory or category
theory whether it's something more in
mathematical physics like conformal
field theory or something I think there
are dictionaries to be made where we
already know some of them where we can
say this thing that we know about from
from this approach to physics or
mathematics or computer science for that
matter corresponds to this other
terminology you know eventual
consistency in distributed database
systems is the same idea as causal
invariant
which is the same idea as the
church-rosser property etc etc etc these
kinds of correspondences which allow us
to kind of knit together sort of the
great advances that are made in these
different areas and as I said I think I
think one of the things that I've sort
of slowly realizing is it's a big
feature of what we're doing is you know
what we have is sort of a rosetta stone
of abstract models um and now we can
kind of wheel in all of these things
that have been figured out in other
abstract models and and start to apply
the things which have been figured out
in those directions of thinking about
abstract models into what we're doing
now I have to say one of the
consequences of that is something I saw
with cellular automata as well which is
any sufficiently simple model ends up
being applicable to many things so for
example with cellular automata cellular
automata are in a sense the most minimal
models one can imagine in which space
and time are inserted and the states of
things are inserted so in cellular
automata they're sort of a rigid lattice
in space there's a rigid sequence in
time and there's sort of rigid choice of
the particular States that exist in the
system and but they're otherwise they're
completely minimal models they assume
nothing beyond those things they are
sort of the minimal parallel computers
in some sense the minimal models of how
computational processes can work in in a
rigid space-time and what's been
interesting over the last 3040 years is
that cellular automata have found their
way into being models of just a huge
diversity of different kinds of systems
not just physical systems but social
systems biological systems all sorts of
systems mathematical systems even that
because of the minimality of those
models because they're sort of minimal
for what they are they end up inexorably
being models for lots of kinds of things
and the same thing is clearly going to
happen and as already starting to happen
with the models that we have for
fundamental physics I mean these models
that just involve transformations for
relations between elements and so on
these are these are very fundamental
models that don't assume a structure of
and time they assume only sort of a
discreteness of existence so to speak
and beyond that they're quite general
and I think sort of I I as I said I kind
of kicked myself for not having realized
that these models were were were
thoroughly exploring 40 years ago when I
started using sort of things based on
this idea to build computational
languages but um nevertheless who we are
where we are and I think these models in
addition to being important for
understanding fundamental physics they
provide sort of a rich source of
modeling I mean I I suppose in some
sense it's a little bit like the story
with calculus I mean originally you know
calculus was invented to serve the needs
of studying celestial mechanics and
physics but actually it's turned out
that calculus is useful for lots of
other kinds of things too and I think in
some sense our models are a little bit
like a a modernised computation alized
kind of not quite the same story because
history never precisely repeats itself
version of something like this sort of
the fundamental idea of a thing like
calculus and as such they're models that
not only apply to fundamental physics
but apply to lots of other kinds of
things and so for example starting to
think about how these models applied to
distributed computing to things like
generalizations blockchain to how they
apply to things like models of
biological evolution all sorts of other
areas so one of the reasons for saying
that is it means that any progress
instead of a fundamental understanding
of these models is something that has
dividends not just for physics but also
potentially for all these other kinds of
areas so it kind of justifies the
abstract study of these kinds of models
and their consequences independent of
just the quest and I say just the quest
for a fundamental theory of physics so
another
thing I want to say is that as we try to
develop intuition about these models we
there's there's one sort of set of
intuition that's relevant that comes
directly from looking at you know you've
got an actual hypergraph and it's
actually being rewritten and you have to
look at the features of that hypergraph
and so on but some of what happens can
also be seen in toy models toy in the
sense that they are they are sort of
structurally simpler in a sense
structurally less abstract than our
generic models with hypergraphs and so
on so for example string substitution
systems where instead of taking this
hyper graph of arbitrary relations
between elements were just saying
there's a string of elements a one you
know a sequence of elements and we're
doing rewritings based on blocks of
these elements there's tons of stuff to
figure out even in the context of of
string substitution systems they're a
good sort of model of our models so to
speak um and you know one of the things
that is sort of potentially a great
irony or a pun or something is that I
suspect that the continuum limit of
string rewriting systems is actually
closely related to the string theory
that's been studied in physics but we'll
see if that pun ends up being reality I
think come it's also worth realizing
that even Turing machines you know I was
recently studying the structure of rule
eel space using as a toy model Turing
machines um and that's again a place
where even though we're not using sort
of the fully abstract sort of hypergraph
rewriting ideas were still able to
understand a sort of an intuition level
things from looking at these kind of toy
models and that seems to be very
valuable and so some of the projects
that I hope will happen at UM at this
summer school both in its physics track
and in the non physics track are studies
of what you know after my big new kind
of science but often gets called MKS
kinds of things
studying the abstract computational
universe in the context of these toy
models as much as in the context of
these Falls sort of hypergraph models
well I would say kind of at the other
end of projects that um I hope will get
done or to take kind of the ideas from
our models of physics and to say okay
given these models can we figure out
actual observable things in the universe
can we actually do the astrophysics the
cosmology the quantum computing whatever
to figure out what does this mean for
the actual universe there's good news
and there's bad news about that the good
news is that structurally we can figure
these things out
the bad news is there are scales that we
just don't know I mean in the case of
you know one if one was thinking about
quantum mechanics abstractly and one
didn't know the value of H bar it will
be hard to know where quantum mechanics
will be relevant you know in the case of
quantum mechanics H bar was sort of
discovered first in our case there's no
sort of in-your-face phenomenon that is
giving us a scale for for what's going
on well maybe maybe we can find that we
have sort of a somewhat rickety argument
but gives us a sense of scale the way to
understand the the emergence of that
scale is in physical space the maximum
rate of information propagation is given
by the speed of light that's the
proportionality the constant of
proportionality that relates spatial
length to time and in our models time is
this kind of thing that that term is
very different from space but is
something that kind of nets its way
through both understanding physical
space-time and understanding quantum
mechanics and even understanding this
more abstract idea of rule space-time is
the same thing throughout all of those
time is the inexorable process of doing
computation time is the is the is is
sort of the the computational
irreducibility of the progress of things
in the universe computational
irreducibility is what kind of makes
time be meaningful so to speak without
computational irreducibility you could
collapse time to nothing you could
get to the end without going through all
the steps computationally reduced
ability is what gives a reality to time
but time ends up knitting its way
through all these different kinds of
levels of description of the universe I
should say also that computational
irreversibility as a as a representation
of time is the thing that also gives us
in the end after such a long time a real
understanding of the second law of
thermodynamics um and it kind of shows
us the deep relation between
thermodynamics relativity quantum
mechanics and actually the fundamentals
of computation um and that's kind of the
great unification that's happening
through the thinking that's that's going
on around around the models that we're
building but in a case the but but back
to kind of observable consequences of
things so there's this notion of of time
and there's an elementary unit of time
in elementary time maybe it's 10 to the
minus 100 and 1 seconds I don't know
that's a that's a guess based on some
some estimate we have um but given that
elementary time we need to know what is
the constant of proportionality to get
the elementary unit of space elementary
distance lower entry lengths and that
constant of proportionality in that case
we know it's the speed of light um
there's a corresponding maximum
information rate in not in physical
space but in this thing we call
branching space the space of quantum
states that maximum entanglement speed
we call that Zeta is a thing it's a
constant of nature like the speed of
light and it has a it has a particular
value but we don't know what their value
is yet maybe that value is 10 to the 5
solar masses per second that's one rough
estimate that we have of it but we need
to know that value in order to be able
to predict certain things about the
actual consequences of that maximum
entanglement speed for physical
phenomena once we know that maximum
entanglement speed we can say things
about limits of quantum computing we can
say things about black hole collapse and
limits on how that
works limited not by the speed of light
but by the maximum speed of entanglement
we can make all kinds of interesting
statements but we don't know the scale
yet you know I think come said a few
times recently that that Einstein was
really lucky in general activity because
he had a scaleless prediction many
predictions that he might have had to
make would involve a scale so for
example many predictions might have
involved the value of the cosmological
constant which he didn't know in fact he
thought you know one of the mistakes he
made was to think gosh the universe
doesn't expand and so therefore I have
to put in this cosmological constant was
kind of a hack in the theory to explain
the lack of expansion of course later on
the expansion of the universe was
observed one of those cases were
something that I've seen a bunch of
times in my life where the elegance of a
theory
outruns what one thinks all was the
experimental kind of consequences I mean
this the same thing happened with Newton
for example you know in in the Principia
you know he tried to do a calculation of
the motion of the moon and he gets the
wrong answer um but he doesn't say well
I got the wrong answer here so the whole
theory is wrong instead well it took
another 100 years before people were
able to work through the mathematics to
get the right answer for that but you
know these things where you run into
into something that seems hard or
doesn't seem quite right you know it's
sometimes it's kind of an in-your-face
problem where you really should should
be worried about your theory but
sometimes it's just like well I didn't
do the math correctly and and in fact in
in the case of general relativity that's
what originally happened for the first
effect that was really an important one
observed the bending of light around the
Sun but then what what came became clear
was that that was a scaleless prediction
that the you know light should be bent
twice as much going around the Sun as
well might think from Newtonian gravity
and that factor of two just because of
its its gravitational electrical
attraction as well as gravitational
magnetism in a sense that factor of two
was then observable the original
experiment was kind of a kind of a bit
of a sham I suspect but nevertheless the
phenomenon was predictable without
knowing a scale without knowing
something like the cosmological constant
so the question is are there similar
predict
from our theory I suspect that there are
a good example of one may be to do with
correlations and photons in orbit around
black holes and that's something that
needs to be looked at from a more sort
of practical physics point of view can
we actually nail that down that may be a
prediction of the existence of an
entanglement horizon that is a scaleless
prediction my guess is there are a few
other scaleless predictions out there
and those will be super interesting to
try to find they're also scale full
predictions which depend on this thing
like you know is the maximum
entanglement speed tenth of live solar
masses per second or whatever there will
be predictions and so just working out
in terms of Zeta just work out
predictions that depend on Zeta what
does that mean for quantum computing
what does that mean for decoherence
speeds for quantum computing my guess is
that the value of Zeta is far away from
practically observable decoherence
speeds but I'm not sure I mean my
current thinking and Jonathan Gord has
been much involved in this and will
probably talk in more detail about it
but about quantum computing is as we
think about quantum computing and is
getting more into technical detail but
but the sort of the process that the
promise of quantum computing has been
that um that there's kind of the your
Treeing out all these these these large
number of possible paths in quantum
mechanics that allows you to do
computations which would normally
involve sort of exponential amounts of
time to be done sequentially by a
classical computer you can sort of
automatically parallelize them in
quantum mechanics the thing that I've
been suspicious about since since the
early 1980s when I started thinking
about quantum computing is that the
measurement process will end up being at
least as much work as that
parallelization process and now that we
have a concrete model of the measurement
so the microscopic steps the measurement
process I think we're going to see that
and a super interesting thing that I
hope will will get explored at this at
the summer school is the actual doing of
practical quantum computing and what it
is what it means in the context to our
models one of the things actually
Jonathan has recently developed is a
compiler that goes from
using framework that we have in Wolfram
language that's been being developed and
more from language which is a
traditional quantum computing framework
and the multi way systems that we have
in our models an actual compiler where
you can say this is a quantum algorithm
represented in traditional quantum
information theory this is its analog in
multi way systems but now in the in the
era of the multi way systems we are
looking we can also see the measurement
process and we can see to what extent we
can actually get this sort of the
quantum part of things to be to be how
that relates to to serve the measurement
process I have a speculation of the last
few weeks that quantum computing gives
you something magic no more effectively
than the expansion of the universe could
give you something magic and physical
space what I mean by that is you know
one is always taught energy is conserved
well actually it's it's not really
conserved in general relativity it's
more complicated story the expansion of
universe gives you a net Hubble flow and
you could imagine doing something where
you you know attach a spring between the
central black holes of - you know
galaxies that are in the Hubble flow and
you could imagine you know the you're
basically putting potential energy into
that spring by using by essentially
taking the energy from the Big Bang and
and using a little bit of it to expand
the spring and in that sense you can
sort of make not quite a perpetual
motion machine which you can kind of
mine energy from nothing you can mine
energy out of the universe by doing that
and so that's obviously something is
very far from being able to be done in
practice so far as we know but you could
in branch field space you may be able to
do a similar kind of thing Rahil space
probably expands like physical space
does I don't know what rate branch field
space is much more of an exponential
space whereas physical space is much
more of a polynomial finite dimensional
space we don't know how the expansion of
branch real space works but presumably
the universe is expanding in branch hill
space as it is in physical space
and the the guests might be that one can
make quantum computing really work
insofar as one is mining they're kind of
the expansion of Branchville space and
again I don't know how bigger that
effect is or what to what can really
happen there maybe it's a much much
bigger effect much much more practical
and much more terrestrial observable
effect than than the effect of the
Hubble flow
um but tub so that's a that's a thing
again to be explored you know I think
there are other sort of pseudo meta
predictions of these theories for
example one of them is when we start
thinking about how particles emerge in
these theories one of the things that
seems to be the case is an electron is
actually really big you know if an
electron is some kind of topological
obstruction in this hyper graph it's a
really big topological obstruction at
least if we're right about the
underlying scales for Rho and Isaiah and
things like that um so if it's really
big that suggests that there actually
exists particles that are much smaller
and of much lower mass than the electron
perhaps ten to the twenty times smaller
and mass than the electron and that's
not something people really have much
reason to investigate and so another
thing that's a question sort of
astrophysics cosmology is okay let's
imagine you did have such a particle and
it participated in the very early
universe potentially it participated in
the stage of the universe at which the
universe might not even have been
three-dimensional what consequences does
that have how would that particle show
up in today's universe credit need Dark
Matter questions like that and that's
really an astrophysics and particle
physics story that can be investigated
where now what's happened is that our
model has provided sort of a a reason to
start thinking about particles like that
that didn't exist before um so that's a
that's in a sense a meta prediction that
doesn't doesn't really say oh there's
going to be a particle of such-and-such
a mass but it gives one the idea that it
might be worth exploring that well
let's see I mean as a practical matter
level you know one of the things that
I'd like to see happen is the sort of as
I say we are at a moment of lots of
low-hanging fruit to be picked we're at
a moment where we have sort of a
methodology and approach a context
framework there's a lot of things to do
and there's a lot of things that won't
even be that difficult to do one of the
things I've kept on saying - - -
Jonathan and Max piss can off I'm
working on this project is you know it
doesn't ever happen this way it's never
this easy I mean in all the times I've
worked on different areas of science and
made various kinds of advances it's
never been the case that so much has
been so easy to get as it has been in
this project now doesn't mean they'll
continue to be that easy maybe we picked
all the easy stuff I don't think so
but it's sort of a remarkable thing
because because of everything that's
happened in physics and so on and
because of the structure that's been
built there you know insofar as we have
found this kind of low-level machine
code for describing what happens
underneath that structure it's
remarkable how easy it is to sort of
pick off things from the existing
structure and now understand more
foundationally how they work so I'm very
hopeful that there's a lot of things to
be figured out there you know one of the
things I hope is going to happen from
this summer school is people are going
to figure those kinds of things out
they're going to really dig deep into
these connections to different kinds of
areas into the kinds of new predictions
that can be made with these with these
models and go write papers about them go
sort of seed the academic literature
with things that can be done on the
basis of them of these models I think
that physics in a sense is in a stage
where it is absolutely ripe for sort of
a place where where all of the talents
of physics can be applied in a fruitful
way we've got a great place to do that
you know I really want to to use the
summer school as a showcase of how that
can really happen and
and how much so I'm I'm hoping for some
classic papers to get written as a
result of work that's done at the summer
school we're going to do our best to
help make that happen and it's kind of a
we have sort of some mechanisms for
presenting these things I think that the
general approach is you know it's some
whoever figures out whatever they figure
out it's up to you to write the paper
about it so to speak
sort of I'm we have this concept of
bulletins I've so far produced two of
these that are kind of progress
bulletins about our project the
bulletins were supposed to be these
little minimal things that were maybe
five pages long the current bulletins
are like 50 or 70 pages long each
because well fortunately or
unfortunately the topics that I started
exploring I just discovered a lot more
than I expected to discover it was a lot
easier going than I expected and so
there was more to say but in any case I
think what sort of the plan is it's like
go figure out a bunch of stuff go write
your own papers about these things you
know I'll probably write some bulletins
that try and pull together sort of the
the threads of what's been figured out
pointing to the specifics of what people
have done and I think that's some you
know jonathan has been writing a bunch
of more academic papers that's been a
very successful thing I think this
project needs to be explained at
multiple levels I think that's another
opportunity and need in terms of people
here is there needs to be sort of an
interpretation of what we're doing both
for people in different fields like
nobody's written yet the I mentioned the
sort of diction Reiter to let's say
string theory the dictionary to
conformal field theory the dictionary to
even general relativity we have a little
bit more of that but writing those
dictionaries that's another very useful
thing to do that in a sense is a is a
very fruitful form of research that is
really the exposition of our models in
the context of a of a framework that
already exists and where there's already
a community of people that understands
that particular framework and that's
another thing I think will be very
valuable to do
it's something which the individual
expertise of a bunch of people who are
who are here I hope will be helpful in
making those connections to these
different areas well I sort of thought
that I would talk a bit about how the
how to think about our model as it is
today um they're not sure how much of
that I'm going to get a chance to do
right now maybe I'll continue that um an
hour slot later this afternoon um or
whatever time it is fear in a few hours
from now um I thought maybe maybe I
should talk a little bit well let me let
me give a little bit of a sketch of of
kind of a current understanding and so a
good place to start let me go ahead and
show this good place to start is this
visual summary that's um that's on the
Wolfram physics project website okay I
should probably point you perhaps other
people have done this to to the
different parts of this website um the
the technical introduction that I wrote
is a kind of a step-by-step kind of
story of of kind of the the foundations
of what we're trying to do jonathan has
two papers which are up here which are
more technical descriptions of how what
we're doing connects to general
relativity and quantum mechanics and
those will be relevant for lots of
people on our physics track here um
the I might say that in in in the kind
of investigations that we do I've sort
of talked around this kind of
methodological approaches there's kind
of the the go used mathematical physics
to figure things out go use theory of
computation to go and figure things out
there's what I often somewhat
disparagingly of myself called doing zu
all
it's like oK we've got some general idea
let's go implement it let's go actually
run simulations of these things and
let's go try and do the zoology so to
speak go study the could be the
computational animals that exists out
there and go see what's going on and
that's a very important step and we've
discovered a lot of very important
things by doing that it's a slightly
different kind of activity than sort of
doing more mathematical physics kinds of
things but it's something that I hope
they'll be projects to do with that I
you know for me I've been doing sort of
computational zoology for 40 years now
and so it kind of its kind of a for me
it's kind of quotes
you know conceptually easy to do I think
there are some principles of how to do
it well having to do with sort of find
the mammal model find the minimal way to
look at things you know one of the
biggest problems in computational
zoology is the unexpected the unexpected
will happen the question is to recognize
it and not to say well I'm just gonna
measure some aggregate quantity and you
know I'm gonna see whether in my in my
space of this aggregate quantity that
I'm looking at anything strange happens
that aggregate quantity may have just
smashed its way through whatever
unexpected thing it was that there was
to discover in this kind of a
computational universe this kind of
computational zoology area so you know
kind of doing the zoology so to speak
it's a step that I think is important
it's also something where to do the
zoology you actually have to understand
what you're talking about because you
actually have to write code that
implements you know if you have some
idea for how causal connectivity works
in the universe and how event horizons
might work in the universe okay actually
write code to implement that actually go
find those event horizons in models and
then you discover oh well actually
there's a bit of a problem it could take
an arbitrarily long time to find that
event horizon there's actually
undecidability involved in this process
etc etc etc it's something where by
trying to do that actual those actual
computer experiments you're forcing
yourself to have a certain level of of
explicitness in a certain level of
understanding of what's going on it's
kind of you know when you do mathematics
there's this idea of sort of the
discipline of actually doing a proof of
trying to dot the i's cross the t's to
figure things out actually doing a
computer experiment involves the same
kind of let's just explicitly get it
right actually what's a lot better than
doing mathematical proof the computer is
a much more efficient sort of receiver
of one's understanding than sort of the
the peer review of mathematical proofs
might be and it's it's a much more a
much more exacting way of under of
making sure that you understand your
understanding so to speak so so pointing
to things here software tools I think
probably people have talked about this
there's a kind of tutorial introduction
to the language tools for actually doing
that kind of computational zoology and
for exploring doing computer experiments
learn those tools because at some moment
even if you think you're doing things in
a mathematical physics level you'll
wonder I wonder how this works well if
you know those tools it's something that
you can just on a whim go explore and
that's really worth being able to do
because often what you discover is not
what you thought you would discover
again it takes some amount of confidence
and using the tools and so on to be able
to know yes I got it right the tools are
actually showing me something that I
didn't expect rather than oh whoops I
didn't expect it there must be something
wrong with the way I'm using these tools
I mean that's one of the great things
about computer experiments
you've just they you it's not like um
doing some biology experiment with a
real mouse or something there isn't a oh
the mouse wasn't feeling well that day
so it did something weird you know it
won't be reproducible and so on computer
experiments it's like you do this
experiment you do it again it's always
going to give the same answer it's
really just it's a much more it's much
more a question of can the
experimentalist really understand you
know create the right experiment and
have the right understanding what they
see any case you know
software tools will help be something
that people learn well here and will
enable them to really explore well label
you all to really explore things in in
these in these areas now I might say if
you kind of wonder what did we figure
out so far these working material
archives we have kind of everything we
have all the notebooks that we've used
for all the livestreams we've done and
so on they're all here so if you kind of
wonder what did we figure out about such
and such a thing and you can go back to
these notebooks and look at what was
actually figured out war we're going to
have hopefully they're coming up in the
next week or so better kind of summaries
using actually the modern video
processing tools in version 12.1 of
welcome language we're going to have
better ways of presenting the the live
streams and the recorded working video
working logs that we have from even
before the project launched and again
you can find things there if you wonder
you know why did they figure why did
they get this thing wrong why were they
so stupid about this particular thing
there's probably an answer to that
question to be found there and then you
can say gosh I figured out the right way
to do it
so that's great um so you know point to
a couple of other things we wrote
recently this glossary that perhaps is
useful if things come up where you don't
know what they are um I might point also
in the technical introduction at the
very end there is a section called graph
types and the appendix that may be
useful and people are talking about
spatial graph causal graph multi-race
states graph all this kind of thing this
is perhaps a useful kind of glossary of
all these different types of graphs that
are going to come up all over the place
um well let me come back now to to sort
of the overall architecture of the
project this visual summary is an
attempt to sort of summarize that so
we're going from this underlying rule
this is just a particular example of
that I would say that the way we state
this rule we state this rule as a set of
sort of
symbolic transformations between
relations between elements there are
probably other ways to state these rules
it could very well be the case that
there is a continuum description of
everything of which this is kind of a
skeleton a little bit like something
like I don't know homotopy cohomology
one of one of these kinds of
constructions in mathematics where there
is a continuous space living underneath
but there is something you describe in a
discreet way that could be an
interpretation of our models in fact I
strongly suspect that it is and that's
something which if we could find it
would potentially unlock the application
of lots of other areas of mathematics to
the understanding of our models so but
in any case in the way that we're
stating it it's kind of it's a
transformation rule for these symbolic
expressions and you can think of it as
transformations fibra graphs and so on
so that's kind of the most underlying
thing in the model then when we apply
that rule many times we get these big
special hyper graphs these big hyper
graphs were the elements we interpret as
kind of atoms of space and we have these
connections between elements that define
the structure of space well so now the
big question is how do we describe that
big special hyper graph we've got this
big spatial hyper graph we can get it by
applying these rules over and over again
get this big thing what on earth is it
how do we have a description of it well
we can measure certain properties of it
we can measure its affective dimension
we can measure its effect of curvature
we can start talking about the structure
of gd6 in it and so on but what really
is it you know is there a model space
that we can use for understanding it in
mathematics when we look at the sort of
continuum model of space we're used to
using manifolds as a way to model what
the structure of space is what is a
manifold the manifold is something which
locally looks like Euclidean space in
some number of dimensions well in these
spatial hypergraphs
we don't necessarily have an integer
number of dimensions some spatial
hypergraphs that we generate do indeed
look like manifolds that are locally you
could in but others are much wilder than
that what is the matter
a medical way of understanding a while
the kind of thing that is the limit of
our special hypergraph maybe it's a
space of 2.7 dimensions we can maybe say
that that it has some effective
dimension but how do we what is the
appropriate model space to use to
understand it how do we how do we build
a mathematics so in a sense calculus was
the story of understanding continuity in
integer dimensional spaces what we need
to understand the limits of these hyper
graphs is an understanding of the of
continuity in things that aren't
necessarily in two-dimensional space
what is the generalization of calculus
that applies to things like this how do
we think about sort of making model
spaces for things like this how do we
think about the constructions of
differential geometry and things like
that in the context of these much Wilder
spaces that come up as the limits not of
some simple mesh or something that might
limit Euclidean space but rather of
these general hyper graphs so that's a
that's an important thing that we are
still sort of grappling with now we can
start kind of picking away using the
ideas of mathematics using notions like
tangent spaces using ideas about
curvature using other kinds of things
that come from traditional mathematics
maybe using ideas about homotopy things
like this that some ideas from topology
and so on um to to understand this limit
of these of these spatial hyper graphs
but I think one of the things that maybe
we'll talk about a bit more as making
this dictionary of from existing
mathematics what is the analog what can
we construct in these special hyper
graphs and so on so that's a that's a
big thing well how do we understand what
the structure of space might be now of
course even talking about the structure
of space is a bizarre thing from the
point of view of existing physics I mean
ever since
Euclid basically there's been sort of
this notion that space is something
where everything operates in it but you
don't have to discuss the structure of
it itself but now so the fundamental to
these models is that we're talking about
the structure of space itself so
there's more to understand about the
structure of it itself space itself
because in these models one of the
features is that we are where everything
in a sense is just space the the whole
everything in our universe is just
features of space and so now that puts
the the the question is how do we
understand matter particles all those
kinds of things just as features of
space and by the way in the in the in
the domain of there's no new idea Under
the Sun
the idea that everything might be just
features of space is an idea that's
existed since antiquity and it's had all
kinds of different twists and turns I
mean one of the ones that was really
kind of nice was Kelvin talking about
some the idea that maybe when when
people believe there was an ether that
was the luminiferous ether that carried
electromagnetic waves as you know air
carries sound waves that there might be
that there might be knots in the ether
and that knots in the ether might
correspond to atoms and so people
started classifying knots that was the
original motivation for knot theory and
classification of knots might correspond
the different kinds of atoms not a great
is it not a completely crazy idea turned
out didn't work in that particular form
but this idea that there's nothing in
the universe except space has certainly
had its precursors for example Einstein
I think very strongly believed that in
fact people keep on sending me these
sermon and maybe maybe somebody should
really do a systematic study of this of
what did Einstein say about discrete
space and about the structure of space
because people sent me a bunch of
fragments where Einstein wrote even as
early as 1916 that look I'm sure spaces
ultimately discrete and not continuous
but we don't have the tools necessary to
analyze things that way at this point in
in the history of mathematics um well
now we do and I think some of Einstein's
ideas about how you know in a sense in
his way of thinking about it everything
might be made from the structure of
gravitational radiation you know jion's
and things like this that would be kind
of just features of space that didn't
work out but now um in our better
understanding our sort of finer
low-level machine code
for what space is we get to actually
think about how everything in the
universe can emerge as something which
is a feature of space and the thing that
we've there one of the surprises in
working on these models in the last six
months was the discovery of the
identification of energy and momentum
with certain features of the set of the
the evolution of space the the idea of
energy as the flux of causal edges
through space like hyper surfaces and so
on more recently we have some
understanding of angular momentum
angular momentum as well as linear
momentum in terms of pairs of jd6 and in
terms of this kind of sweeping out of a
plane and in terms of sort of vorticity
in in the structure of causal graphs and
so on so in any case one of the things
that is so something we don't have is an
understanding of quantum angular
momentum I have some guesses Jonathan
has some different guesses about the use
of things like homotopy in understanding
the among other things the quantization
of angular momentum um I suspect there's
some low-hanging fruit to be picked
there I suspect once that's picked we
will also understand fermions and bosons
which are another thing that sort of is
a feature so one question is do you need
to know what particles are to understand
for example what energy is or what
angular momentum is so I thought one we
probably would need to understand
particles before and understood energy
turns out it isn't true
there's a bulk notion of energy that
exists in our models there's a bulk
notion of angular momentum a question
which I think is a very immediate one is
is there a bulk notion of spin
statistics is there a bulk notion of
Fermi statistics of fermions and so on
I'm kind of beginning to suspect that
there is a bulk notion of that and that
that's something that one can explore
without knowing the details of how
things break down into individual
particles but now the question is what
are these particles they are presumably
some analog of a topological obstruction
in the structure of the spacial
hypergraph and in its evolution we know
sort of toy examples of non planar lumps
in planar
laughs things like this what is the more
general analog of that we don't know
that's a super important thing that's
something that I think can be studied by
computer experiments and we need to do
that now I should say that that term so
so understanding the structure of what
can happen in a spatial hypergraph
that's an important thing there's a
theoretical understanding that may be
difficult I mean you know I've talked to
a bunch of the world's leading graph
theorists in the past actually about
sort of generalizing notions of
topological obstructions and graphs and
they say things like well come back in a
hundred years we may know something
which is which is basically alike you've
got to figure it out for yourself and so
we need to figure out perhaps using
experiments perhaps using theoretical
ideas that may be sort of newly emerging
what can we say about some about sort of
the particle structure and spatial
hypergraphs
I should say there are other things that
we need to generalize so for example
rotational invariance how does it work
in 22.7 dimensional space what is the
arrow out of the rotation group in that
case what's the way in which we can get
just as we think we can get a limit of
the spatial hypergraph to a manifold can
we get a limit of its internal
solitaries tually group answer is
probably yes I have some definite ideas
about how that might work in terms of
sort of buckets of permutations and how
the limits of these buckets of
permutations might end up being a league
Roop essentially a sort of a group group
with a manifold kind of thing
it's actually amusing that term as I
looked at the history of attempts to
find finite approximations to lis groups
I found there's not a lot of literature
on that but one of the key papers was
written by a certain Alan Turing who
concluded that there wasn't a good way
to find a finite approximation to Li
groups now with the ultimate irony if
kind of the things that emerge from his
Turing machines are exactly the way that
one can understand that but so
understanding Li groups you know s OD
for fractional dimensional D that's an
example of something that I think we
have an opportunity to do from our
models that will be important
mathematics but it's also something that
we need and analyzing what we're trying
to do in terms of physics
well so from a spatial hypergraph the
story is we make a causal graph that
represents the court the network of
causal relationships between updating
events in our spatial graph and it's
that causal graph in which we start
talking about relativity we start
talking about reference frames we start
talking about those kinds of things kind
of a a realization of recent times as
that we think about things in terms of
category theory we can think about kind
of spatial hypergraph potentially a sort
of a generalization of one categories of
ordinary categories but done in a bulk
way just like ink just like I was
talking about for some Baalak
expressions the way I've been thinking
about symbolic expressions is they mean
something but what we see in this model
is it's just a giant bucket of symbolic
expressions that don't mean anything or
actually they mean everything because
they represent the whole universe but
they are sort of locally just
meaningless infrastructure and so
similarly with category theory ones used
to thinking about you know objects and
categories is actually meaning something
having an interpretation that one can
describe potentially sort of the bulk
version of that is something closer to
what we're talking about in the universe
so one categories potentially correspond
to things like spatial hypergraph to
current categories actually correspond
potentially to the causal graph and to
the causal relationships between events
now this idea of a causal graph is very
general idea it's in a sense what
Einstein was going for in the
construction of special relativity but
it's something which has arisen so many
times it's arisen in computation as it's
some kind of execution history graph
every event is the operation of a
function that function has certain input
it that input needs to have been
computed as the output from some
previous function that's the the sort of
flow of data in this computational
system and so that gives us an
understanding this causal graph is this
way of representing this sort of flow of
computation and by the way recent ideas
about sort of generalizing blockchain
have to
do with thinking about sort of a causal
graph a blockchain is just sort of a
one-dimensional sequence of things that
happen in time the causal graph is the
general distributed version of that and
there's sort of a question of thinking
about that and thinking about sort of
uncertainly principles for money and
things like that we can talk about that
another time the but in any case from
this court all graph one of the big
questions then is reference frames in
relativity we're used to things like
inertial frames those correspond to kind
of flat slices through this causal graph
what do what are other reasonable frames
what is a calculus of frames how do we
think about the set of possible frames
that one might consider that might be
constructible by a computationally
bounded observer Jonathan has some
thoughts about how thinking about that
relates to things like the weak cosmic
censorship hypothesis I think that's
some that's a way of thinking about some
of these kinds of things we don't even
know what an accelerated frame looks
like and that's a a constructible kind
of frame that one can see what the
consequences are and in fact for example
we know that part of a production like
in Hawking radiation happens and
accelerated frames we should see that if
we make explicit models of accelerated
frames in in the causal graph and so on
hasn't hasn't been done yet
um the so then this this whole question
about what's a reasonable reference
frame the causal graph big set of
questions there that set of questions
also relates to distributed computing my
expectation is to assume you're
computing is very hard to wrap your your
head around you know how do you get all
these independent asynchronous processes
to all do the right thing
the traditional approach and distributed
computing is make them somehow
synchronize so you don't actually have
to think about the the distributed
nature of the thing you really have
ultimately synchronised all of them in a
series of steps that's a very
inefficient way to do distributed
computing I think we have the
opportunity to start thinking as we do
in thinking about generativity thinking
about sort of these reference frames of
in which we are doing
thinking about computation and that's a
way to that well I think emerge is a way
to think about distributed computing
that is is different from from from from
the ways we've thought about it before
but can leverage all those things we
know in physics you know we'll be able
to talk about event horizons in
distributed computing kind of forks in
the blockchain and things like this and
we'll be able to take all that intuition
and all that mathematical development
that's happened in physics and apply it
to distributed computing so that's the
causal graph the next big thing is the
multi way graph and the multi way graph
represents all the ambiguities in the
possible rewritings that could be done
there isn't just one place you can do a
particular rewriting in the spatial
hypergraph there may be many the multi
way graph represents the the graph of
all those possible rewritings
and it's the thing that leads sort of
inexorably to quantum mechanics and the
idea is that in this multi way graph
there are all these different possible
states that can emerge that are like the
states of quantum mechanics and we can
start to see kind of the the easy ideas
of quantum mechanics can emerge just in
talking about the multi way graph we
don't really have to go further beyond
that and we only have to talk about
spatial aspects of it we just say the
structure of the multi way graph is this
oh I should have mentioned so a key idea
here is this idea of causal and variance
which we'll talk about much more
technically but it's the idea that leads
the branching that happens in this multi
way graph always to have some
corresponding merging in the future it's
the thing that leads to the invariance
of of different the fact that the when
you make different foliation zuv the
causal graph you always get the same
physics that's the analog of the
statements of relativity that you you
always get the same physics independent
of the reference frame the independent
the inertial frame that you're in but
okay so in in quantum mechanics we have
this notion of the multi way graph now
one of the conceptual advances I think
is this idea of quantum observation for
the analog for quantum mechanics of
reference frames for for space-time and
this notion that there are that we can
think about a quantum observation frame
and that that's a way of thinking about
measurement processes and other kinds of
things we can think about of a
superposition of states we can think
about kind of freezing a state to
correspond to freezing a state in the
coordinate system that we're using to
describe the world to correspond to
having made a measurement of that state
and we can think about sort of the the
trade-off just like in general
relativity between coordinate
singularities and actual singularities
in space-time those kinds of things so
one of the things that happens in this
multi way graph is that we can if we
look at the foliation z-- of the
multi-way graph these sequences of
reference frames or the reference frame
in a sequence of a sequence of slices in
time we find that the those slices
correspond to these things we call
branch field graphs these graphs that
represent the the entanglements the
shared common ancestry between different
states the way that these states are
entangled so in the case of the ordinary
spatial ordinary causal graph the
foliation x' the slices through the
ordinary course of graph are
instantaneous versions of the spatial
hyper graph in the case of the multi-way
graph the instantaneous slices are
Branchville graphs they are graphs that
represent the instantaneous entanglement
of quantum states and so one of the
things that we are we've realized is
that just as we can think of physical
space as an extent of physical space as
being something which emerges from the
slicing of the causal graph so similarly
we can think of the an extent of
branchial space of the space of quantum
entanglements as being something which
emerges from the slicing of this
multi-way graph and branch field space
is sort of as much a thing as physical
space but it's a space and we can start
talking about ideas about motion and
branch real space properties of branch
real space limiting structure a branch
real space
to what extent is the limiting structure
of bronchial space what is the right
model for the limiting structure of
grant real space is it like a projective
Hilbert space perhaps is the multi way
causal graph like a twister space we
don't know these are things to figure
out once we have those analogies we can
start figuring out all kinds of things
about physics that emerges from from
that that way of thinking about things
but first of all we just have this idea
of Branch Hill space and we can start
thinking about things like motion and
Branch Hill space event horizons in
Branch Hill space all these kinds of
things
so in physical space one of the big
things that we've been able to do is
derive the Einstein equations as the
continuum limit the large-scale limit of
this spatial hyper graph now I should
say you know I did a sort of an early
derivation of those things in the 1990s
the ping here the I want to what I'm
gonna do here is I'm kind of this
there's too much to say about all of
this so I'm spending longer talking
about this than I'd expected I'm going
to finish talking about sort of this
round of stuff then we'll go to our
virtual pizza party and then I'll come
back and I'll talk some more about some
some more things to say about kind of
the structure of the model and the
opportunities that exist today in
understanding it but I want to talk
about some general relativity in the
derivation of general relativity
um the in a sense that derivation is an
analogue for spacial hypergraphs
of what I did with cellular automata and
fluid mechanics back in the 1980s
technically and mathematically more
sophisticated probably even some of the
things I did from fluid mechanics
actually to do with group theory and so
on might actually be applicable even
quite directly now that I think about it
too what we're doing here and that's
probably something worth exploring but
any case the the derivation general
relativity we worked on it and Jonathan
has a sort of more button-down version
of it but there's still more to figure
out there in when one does sort of the
mathematics of it there are many limits
to be
taken there are many assumptions to be
made about ogre DISA tea about which
sort of a thing from computational
irreducibility there are many things
about we want a limit where the length
scales are large compared to the
elementary length small compared to the
size of the universe that could the
derivatives that the the the rates of
change of things are small compared to
this large compared to that it's a big
tower of limits and there's a lot to be
done in sort of mathematically buttoning
that down and in figuring out perhaps
with experiments and so on where that
tower of limits doesn't work because
those are going to be physical phenomena
so in any case the we have this
derivation of the Einstein equations and
and we you know an example of something
that's really actually I think I forgot
to put that on our list of potential
project but it should be there is can
you derive the higher order Corrections
to the Einstein equations in the case of
fluid mechanics with cellular automata I
did derive the next order corrections to
to the to the fluid equations that come
where you don't they're not just things
completely generic to to to what's going
on but they're things that depend a
little bit on the actual structure of
the molecules so similarly we want to
know what are the next order Corrections
the things that depend a little bit more
on the underlying structure of the space
that that's a that's a good project that
I forgot to put on the list um and we
should add but so I'm not saying it's
easy I know Jonathan has done some work
on this I think this is a something
where there's there's things to figure
out okay let's go to bar filled space
now this idea of motion and gd6 and
things that we can set up in physical
space we can also set up a branch real
space and one of the just amazingly cool
things is that the Fineman path integral
basically is the analog of the Einstein
equations but in broad Shields space
rather than in physical space and so
what we're talking about is the turning
the deflection of gd6 as a result of the
presence of Lagrangian density
essentially energy density in in the
multi way graph now again there
details to be filled in you know I would
say let's go make a perfect mathematical
derivation of the path integral but
actually even the perfect mathematics of
the path integral is not properly
understood and hasn't been in 70 years
as I mentioned earlier so there's some
but there's more that can be done in
sort of buttoning down the derivation of
the path integral from looking at the
structure of multi-way graphs are
looking at the continuum limit of
multi-way graphs um some of what happens
there may relate to the phony on boseong
question and other kinds of things like
that but the other thing to understand
is sort of the predictions of quantum
mechanics one of the things that sort of
one of the challenges in making sort of
a new paradigmatic approach to a field
particular field that's had sort of a
hundred years of of kind of sort of
opportunity to develop since its last
kind of real real injection of new
paradigms is you know what was done
wrong what were the things that we
assumed that became sort of self-evident
to anybody working in physics you know
six or seven academic generations away
from the people who created the current
paradigm what are things that sort of
are taken for granted by anybody who's
doing that and there are several of
those I mean one being the discreteness
of space another being the the
identification of space and time is the
same kind of thing which was something
that I think minkovski was primarily
responsible for the idea that time is
just a coordinate like space as opposed
to something different like a
computational process as opposed to an
extent of a hypergraph but one of the
things that we've realized about quantum
mechanics is there's a similar
identification I think I don't know the
history I need to go look up the history
I kind of suspect John von Neumann was
one of the was was the maybe Vigna maybe
maybe to some extent Heisenberg with a
responsible for this particular thing
which I think is a wrong turn in the end
the idea that a quantum amplitude is a
complex number and that's the right way
to think about it seems to be wrong that
is it seems to be yes you can package
what we think of as quantum mechanics as
a single work wantem attitudes are
complex numbers but actually you should
be thinking about the magnitude and the
phase
of the complex number in a separate way
the magnitude turns out to be associated
with path counting of PARs in the multi
way graph the phase is associated with
position and branch Hill space and so
when we work out the path integral isn't
it remarkable that the path integral has
a measure which is just where has some
the actual sort of content of the path
integral the thing you're you're
integrating is e to the is over H bar
it's a pure phase and and there's a
separate measure that you're integrating
over and those that measure I think is
the path counting of the multi way graph
the thing you're integrating the actual
each of the is over H bar that
represents turning in branch heel space
that represents I think the deflection
of jd6 in branch hill space and that's
the thing and sort of I mean I I back in
the early 80s I I talk to dick Feynman a
lot and one of the questions that he
would always raise is why is the e to
the minus beta H of thermodynamics the
same exponential as the e to the HT of
quantum mechanics why is there that same
kind of thing why is and I don't think
that was the ultimately the right
question but that was a question that is
like why does quantum mechanics have
just this complex phase that's related
to energy I think we know the answer now
and I think the answer was sort of
confused by thinking about things in
terms of complex numbers rather than
thinking about sort of the phase are
separate from the magnitude but there's
a lot to figure out here about sort of
going through the standard derivations
of quantum mechanics going through how
bells inequalities work how you know
quantum harmonic oscillators work all
these kinds of things in the context of
this way of understanding sort of the
the low-level machine code of quantum
mechanics and I think what we've got as
I mentioned the sort of the the
compilation from quantum computing
quantum information framework to multi
way systems we think we have a way of
doing that but there are other quantum
phenomena I mean think of any
you know harm
bohm affect the you know and any one of
these kinds of quantum effects you know
cuantos quantum Zeno effect okay we
actually understand we think we
understand that it's the element of time
dilation in brass real space um but
there are all these different quantum
effects and and it's important to try to
understand each of those in the context
of of this multi way graph um so we
should wrap up here in a moment and go
to our virtual pizza party I just
mentioned two more things here and now
I'm going to go on and talk some more
about the structure of this model later
um the thing I'll mention is that just
as we're talking about sort of compiling
quantum computing into multi wave
systems and that is a very productive
way of actually understanding more about
quantum computing I think another very
productive direction is taking for
example our causal graph structure and
using it to do numerical relativity you
know when we work out black hole mergers
and things there's a lot of complexity
in the way that you try and discretize
the Einstein equations to do that the
causal graph may provide a much better
way to do that that doesn't lead to sort
of immediately unphysical kinds of
things that come out because of the way
you do the discretization
similarly discretizing the multi way
graph and the multi way causal graph I
think can lead to a discretization of
quantum field theory that is more
effective than lattice gauge theory and
things like that but this case there is
had to do this embarrassing thing of
rotating in space times Euclidean space
that's something that I don't think will
be necessary here and this is
potentially a way to in practice do more
analysis upon field theory alright I
think we should wrap up for now here and
go to our virtual pizza party I should
say just a piece of a little footnote to
history that might amuse people the the
the technology we're going to use for
our virtual pizza party as a system
called high fidelity and okay here's the
footnote to history so I am as I know
whether it's a hobby or something else
but I
I advise tech companies on things it's
it's it's easier to advise somebody
else's company sometimes than to then to
advise oneself on one's own company so
it's it's kind of I think of it as a as
a form of I don't know it's quite
relaxation it tends to be it tends to be
you mostly hear from companies when
there's a giant panic going on so it's
not always as as relaxing as it might be
but anyway I I I have a sort of pseudo
hobby of advising tech companies and so
one company I've advised for a long time
as a company called high fidelity that
was created by the person who did the
second life virtual world for Rosedale
and he in high fidelity his objective
was to make a peer-to-peer a virtual
world that would be inhabited by people
with virtual reality head gear and
things like this and this was sort of
leveraging the idea that virtual reality
was going to be here now well
unfortunately virtual reality isn't here
now fortunately Phil raised a lot of
money for his company and it's done a
lot of very good R&D towards the the
goal of making this kind of true virtual
world
okay well two months ago now I was
thinking about this summer school and I
was thinking about how are we going to
do how are we going to replicate in
virtual environment some of the nice
things that happen in the physical
summer school and one of the nice things
is kind of just informal groups of
people gathering being able to sit in
some space and study and people wander
up and talk to them and so on how are we
gonna be able to replicate that kind of
experience in in the virtual world so to
speak and I thought gosh I wonder if
Phil's technology would let us do this
so I sent mail to Phil and said I think
there's really an opportunity here take
this technology that you have and build
a way to make virtual gatherings that
that that people can use in which it's
not like zoom where it's kind of either
a very organized breakout room or just a
very much a set of everybody is on
together and is in
same conversation kind of environment so
anyway it was one of those happy cases
where a little bit of an input caused
something big to happen and Phil really
pivoted his company to work on this
special audio technology which they had
developed over the course of many years
to provide this environment that is
named after their company high fidelity
an environment for doing virtual
gatherings in which one can have lots of
people in a virtual space and we get to
move around little dots in that virtual
space and we get to hear spatial audio
that corresponds to the audio that term
we would hear in in so a real
environment
now there's complicated physics there's
complicated computation in doing the
mixing of that audio and I'd been
continually pushing Phil to improve the
sound attenuation functions and things
like this there's still physics to
figure out there hopefully what we'll
experience here we've been using this
for some events and bunch of other
people have been been using it term for
different kinds of virtual events but
remember that this is still early stage
technology but I think it's a very good
way to have something where one can
break into multiple conversations and
we'll be using that throughout the
summer school to to provide that kind of
experience and anyway let's go there in
a minute and we can all start to I hope
a track there and I will be back sort of
on camera in zoom in what is it about
two and a bit hours and I will continue
talking about the structure of our
models I think I'll talk a bit about the
actual proposed projects that term we've
suggested for for the summer school we
might talk a little bit about the
sociology of science and the experience
of introducing sort of paradigmatically
new things in science
we'll take it from there so I will see
you guys some in in high fidelity in a
minute and then we'll be talking again a
bit later all right well welcome to the
summer school I'm hoping and expecting
great things to happen here look forward
to the next few weeks okay
bye from here